انا تابعت بالصدفه وعلى تويتر قبل ما اذهب
الى هذا الحفل
الجميل الانيق المجموعه من النساء البلد
المواطنات الشريفات الحرات في مشهد لم اكن
اتخيله انا وجيلي ذكرني بمشاهد جيل والدتي
اولئك الفلاحات
طبعا كن يعاملنا من الفجر الى المغرب
ويعمل احيانا اكثر من الرجال ولم يكن
الباحث في كل مكان زراعته في كل مكان في
كل مكان زراعي وبالتالي هذا المشهد لانه
احنا دائما نتحدث الرجال الامن والرجال
الامن اعتقد ان هناك الان مصطلح جديد اسمه
نساء الامن وسيبرز وسيدرك المتخلفون ان
المراه الحره السعوديه ستشارك في كل شيء
لن ينجحوا في منعها من كل شيء بعد ان
قلبوها من انسانه من كائن عاقل حر مستقل
الى عار وعوره انا اعتقد ان هذه بشره خير
وسترى في المستقبل القريب ما يسرك
وبالتالي هذا المفهوم او هذا المصطلح
سيكبر هذه الشجره بدرت
ولن انسى عناق اقرباء هؤلاء النساء
وتقديمهم الورد
وقريبه وهم يحتفلون بها لاحظ معي الانقلاب
جدري في المفاهيم وارجو ان يستمر